en Ecuador avanza un nuevo estado de
emergencia declarado por el presidente
Guillermo lasso debido a los ataques de
bandas criminales por la transferencia
además de mil criminales desde la cárcel
es del litoral o guayas hasta otros
centros penitenciarios el martes pasado
de estructuras del ligadas al
narcotráfico realizaron al menos 18
atentados seguidos con explosivos y se
hallaron dos cadáveres Colgando en un
puente de esmeraldas las acciones de
terror se sumaron a los motines en la
penitenciaría del litoral ubicada en el
puerto de Guayaquil en resistencia a
esta transferencia de prisioneros al
menos dos reos murieron y cinco más
quedaron heridos 15 policías se
recuperan de sus heridas por los
enfrentamientos en los últimos dos años
al menos 400 presos han muerto en
motines carcelarios eso sin un efectivo
control de las autoridades y la política
de pacificación de Guillermo lasso
parece causar el efecto contrario vamos
a ir al análisis con Fernando Carrión él
es analista político y académico de
flacso Ecuador Fernando gracias a usted
y se considera que al menos 20 bandas
delictivas se han formado en Ecuador y
que estarían integradas por unos 40.000
miembros entre locales y extranjeros que
es lo que ha favorecido la formación de
estas bandas que tienen un dominio
evidente de las cárceles
Bueno yo creo que aquí hay por lo menos
dos dos tres fenómenos que explicarían
esto en primer lugar Obviamente que hay
un incremento sustancial de la
producción de cocaína en los países
fronterizos del caso de Perú duplicó en
estos últimos dos años y el caso de
Colombia Pues en un 25 30% más y el
ecuador está en la mitad con una
bajísima capacidad institucional por
otro lado se produjo una mutación en la
relación de los carteles internacionales
llámese Sinaloa Jalisco Nueva Generación
con los locales en términos de que ya no
les pagan desde hace cuatro años más o
menos en en dólares y no les pagan en
droga eso obligó a que estos carteles se
organicen mejor y que empiecen a vender
en el mercado interno con lo cual el
Ecuador empieza a ser uno de los países
consumidores esto ha tenido su
contraparte efectivamente dentro de las
cárceles y fuera de las mismas bueno y
hablemos de decisión de transferencia de
reos para usted fue una medida adecuada
o una medida desesperada que otras
opciones había
Bueno la verdad es que el sistema
carcelario es de una institución pública
que está funcionando al margen de la ley
y esto es muy claro por qué Porque por
ejemplo la cárcel que hoy día es la más
grande y la más compleja que es la
penitenciaría del litoral tiene 12
pabellones y más o menos 9.000 personas
privadas de la libertad Cada padre
vellón es manejado por una de estas
organizaciones lo que decidió el
gobierno nacional es cambiar la lógica
de clasificación de los presos porque
antes se clasificaba en función de sus
adscripciones a las organizaciones
delictivas y no de acuerdo a los tipos
penales decir a los grados de de
violencia que generaban Y entonces esto
ha hecho que en esta última cena semana
se haga una reubicación masiva de
alrededor de
2.400 personas privadas de la libertad
hacia dos recintos carcelarios uno en la
provincia de manabí y otro en Guayaquil
mismo que se llama la roca
así como dentro del del de la propia
cárcel de la penitenciaría electoral
vamos a ver si es que eso hace que el
estado el sector público pueda recuperar
el gobierno del sistema carcelar Bueno y
esas movilizaciones de reos fueron las
que causaron estos episodios de
violencia y Estos son motines que además
se repiten en las cárceles ecuatorianas
desde el año 2019 en 2022 el problema
evidentemente sigue sin solucionarse Por
qué se está abordando tan tardíamente
yo creo que ese es el gran problema este
rato hay cinco diagnósticos hechos por
cinco instituciones distintas la
asamblea nacional la Comisión
Interamericana de Derechos Humanos una
comisión de pacificación etcétera y ahí
se han hecho muchas recomendaciones y
desgraciadamente no se ha sumido el tema
recién este fin de semana o esta semana
que acaba de pasar desde el primer día
de de este mes Se entró con una política
de ese tipo que a mí me parece acertada
pero que es lo que ocurre nosotros ya
sabemos en el Ecuador y en América
Latina que cuando hay reubicaciones se
producen hechos fuera de las cárceles y
dentro de las cárceles en el caso del
Ecuador no hemos vivido por primera vez
yo diría la semana con los mayores
grados de violencia a lo largo de toda
la historia del Ecuador se produjeron
más o menos 18 coches bomba algo que
nunca habíamos tenido 18 coches bombas
este incendios la gasolineras a tiendas
a unidades de policía comunitaria
fallecieron asesinaron
seis policías ha sido una cosa
francamente importante y cuando como
decía esto ya se conoce entonces lo que
se debería haber hecho es por un lado la
reo ubicación Pero por otro lado pues
tomar las decisiones correspondientes
para que no ocurra lo que finalmente
ocurre bueno y mire la guerra contra las
drogas ha sido uno de los frentes para
luchar contra la inseguridad y es uno de
los temas que se viven ahora en Ecuador
y que han llevado a esta reubicación de
presos pero quiero preguntarle Usted
cree que ha funcionado esta estrategia
en la región vale la pena que Ecuador
continúe con ese enfoque o hay que
repensar allá Cómo es que se lucha
contra la inseguridad
no yo creo que hay que repensarlo la
guerra de las drogas tiene ya 54 años en
el mundo y era una política que uno
podría decir que era interesante porque
era afectar las zonas de producción que
es básicamente por ejemplo la cocaína
son los países andinos y entonces si es
que uno afectaba eso no llegaba a los
Estados Unidos Pero qué es lo que
ocurrió esto se generalizó la cantidad
de personas que han muerto los recursos
económicos que tienen la penetración al
mercado la penetración la sociedad la
penetración en el sector público ha sido
francamente impresionante yo creo que
eso ahora de empezar a pensar de cambios
en esa lógica y me parece que
tendencialmente ya estamos en esa línea
por ejemplo Canadá ya legalizó el
consumo el consumo en en su país de de
la marihuana el presidente biden Hace
aproximadamente hace aproximadamente 15
días también pues y hizo una amnistía
para 6.500 personas que habían consumido
o traficado incluso marihuana en los
Estados Unidos hay 37 estados que
consumen legalmente con fines
medicinales y 19 con con fines con fines
recreativos Yo creo que es ahora ya de
que en América Latina empecemos una
discusión respecto de la despenalización
de la droga y señor Carreón Mientras
tanto el ambiente es de miedo entre los
integrantes de la policía que no ven los
recursos suficientes para controlar
estos o brotes de violencia sin
precedentes es un temor fundamental
Sí porque lo que nosotros tenemos es
policías que tiene que pagarse sus
uniformes policías que tienen que
pagarse sus propios chalecos antibalas
que tiene que pagarse su estadía en los
lugares donde donde tiene que ir a
trabajar la comida etcétera o que los
municipios tienen que proveer estos
recursos acaba de presentarse la
proforma presupuestaria para el próximo
año y hay un incremento del 3%, nada más
que el 3% para la policía y nada más que
para la policía Porque todavía estamos
en un enfoque exclusivamente represivo
donde los dos actores centrales son la
policía y las fuerzas armadas pero no se
tienen absoluto ninguna otra política
que entienda a mejorar las situaciones
de seguridad del país